como decía lo mío no es normal muchas
veces cuando digo esto que lo menos
normal es pensar que andar con flow y
mazo rollazo que yo tengo que mandado
mis piernas o como yo llamo mis quinces
a bailongas pero la verdad que no no lo
digo por eso lo pongo como vida
totalmente diferente que los contaré esa
cosa y me suele pasar es que este flow
molones ahora son no se les va a asociar
la idea de que vengo contra la típica
historia superación personal en la que
chico con discapacidad supera sus
barreras físicas y consigue vivir una
vida plena
guau lucha por tu sueño david campeón
bueno ahora vengo a eso realmente venga
desmonta la discapacidad de arriba abajo
más que nada vuestras historias son
aburridas no es tan simple basadas en
ese paradigma en el que las personas con
discapacidad somos o pobrecitos o
superhéroes bueno y espérate ahora
gracias a fresh eso es una cosa más
somos campeones
no sabéis de verdad lo que a mí me gusta
de pequeño con campeón una cosa
maravillosa a ver con 5 o 6 años venga
para delante pero cuando tiene 26 dos
carreras en una casa de una pareja de
gatos persas' y es un hombre hecho
y derecho es de tobillo derecho no estoy
al este torció así por un lado pero
y no no me gusta campeones a ver
te ríes un montón vale pero no me gusta
para mí no es la película está vendido
que va a explicar que la discapacidad de
verdad y cuál su realidad porque para mí
entre risa y risa es lo que se pierde no
esa realidad y esa magia que para mí es
la discapacidad
y bueno es lo que ven y no contamos la
otra cara de la discapacidad
generalmente no se cuenta así que vamos
a empezar el primer cliché con el que
rompo no es con esa idea de que las
personas con discapacidad somos ejemplos
de superación personal por superar
nuestra discapacidad vale pues para mí
eso no es real o sea la discapacidad
realmente no se supera yo la igualó a lo
que son los problemas y los miedos no
que todos tenemos sí que o sea que no se
olvida y déjanos lados sino que se viven
por momento que los vives los íntegras
en ti y lo que al principio era un
problema pasa a ser una gran virtud y
eso genera un crecimiento una cuestión
personal brutal y para mí ahí sí está mi
superación personal no en como deje de
ser un idiota egoísta que no hacía nada
por nada y pensaba que el mundo girar
alrededor se obligó a ser un idiota eso
como veis no cambio pero que esta vez
intentaba que todo ese esfuerzo vale la
mayor un número de personas generan un
cambio social que valiera para todos y
remarcó para todos porque hoy en día uno
de los temas más influyentes que hay en
la sociedad es el gran dilema de cómo
conseguir la igualdad pues vale aquí
también le voy a dar un giro de tuerca
al asunto normalmente lo que se hace
para conseguir la igualdad de un sector
discriminado como en este caso pues es
la discapacidad es empoderar este propio
sector pues yo te diría que esto no vale
para nada porque te digo esto pues es un
tipo empírico
venga probable mis carnes lo que yo
quería conseguir la igualdad y voy a
poder a medida apoderar que soy chucho
abrimos paréntesis vales voy a explicar
qué es esto de ser chucho es decir qué
le pasa a este en la cabeza
como todos sabéis desde que nacemos nos
etiquetan nos marcan y lo meten en cajas
y a mí me tocó una etiqueta maravillosa
que es la de discapacitado o minusválido
increíble y la que más cachondo me pone
disminuido
espectacular
pero claro como comprenderéis joven no
me gustaba y me cree que es que me puse
la etiqueta de una osa una con más
fluido más molón como yo no y me puse la
de chucho que vivendi motivo de su
churri o mal hecho anormal como yo ya se
haya avisado que era un poco idiota vale
bueno ponemos al tema no yo me en poder
lo digo venga david que la impopular el
mundo que tú puedes con todo si utilizan
algo no puedes tú coges y lo haces y
encima les haces una peineta vamos y va
súper encaminado la igualdad de una cosa
más que nada porque todo ese mensaje iba
a rodeado una rabia y un enfado por no
haber sido aceptado como yo consideraba
que tenía que haber aceptado increíbles
y se suele sumas que llega un momento
que pasas la línea y empezás a mirar a
la gente con encima del hombro como
diciendo de que esté torcido así pero
mira que lo conseguido no tú con tu
correcto y quejándote de todo pues muy
bien no iba la menos mal que me di
cuenta no hay un paso atrás eso sí a mi
ritmo y con flow y es lo que me sirvió
para aprender lo que la verdadera
igualdad no se consigue empoderando un
sector discriminado la sociedad como
decía sino empeorando lo que nos une y
que nos une que eso discapacitado y tú
no que yo soy hombre y tu mujer lo que
nos une es que todos y cada uno de
nosotros somos diferentes
somos humanos está claro que todos
caminamos yo con flow vale pero todos
caminamos hoy todos vemos la vida pasada
solo que hay gente que hace consejos
cerrados y la siente todos tenemos
sentido del humor solo que hay gente
pues bueno que no tiene filtros no y da
igual lo que piso los demás y se ríe de
todo por lo tanto lo mío no es normal
pero lo tuyo lo tuyo todos vosotros
tampoco lo es lo que ocurre es que en
esta sociedad no el concepto de la
normalidad de la diferencia se ve como
algo negativo y no nos damos cuenta que
es nuestra mayor virtud ya estas
diferencias
vale son las generaciones especiales y
si las unimos podemos generar grandes
cambios en esta sociedad
cuando tú te das cuenta de esto no dices
vale y en qué momento me diferencia en
este caso mi discapacidad pasa a ser
algo negativo porque yo me acordaba de
cuando era niño y es que los niños no
ven diferencias y si las ven a
normalizarse o sea ellos no ven
diferencias entre hombre y mujer el
color de piel
si tienes o no tienes flow es único
objetivo en la vida es jugar y ser
felices y en qué momento la hemos
cagado y yo pensaba y pensaba y pensaba
y recordemos es una anécdota no con 78
años yo iba a salir del colegio con un
amigo y cuando llegamos hasta las madres
una de ellas a mi compañero hoy es
fulanito ten cuidado con david que
tienen problemas las piernas y claro
pobrecita hay que ayudarle hay con esa
pena yo dejé de ser uno más para ser uno
menos y por eso siempre hablo dos tipos
de discapacidad la que vive el niño que
no la vive que él es feliz y la que vive
la familia que es la social que es la
jodida que la que tiene concepto
negativo
brutal la sólo vale con leer no la
definición de discapacidad de la rae
característica de la persona que la
impide o dificulta su realización
personal
brutal o entonces claro el sector la
discapacidad digamos que esto no le
gustaba mucho no dijo venga esto no me
mola que yo romper este término y me ha
quedado otro y se crea uno maravilloso
que también me gusta mucho que es
diversidad funcional
no no me gusta y voy a explicar por qué
no me gusta porque imágenes como si me
de llamarte tonto te llaman tontito que
el fracaso lo mismo si si reír o pero es
que verdad
el problema no está en la palabra como
tal que es como un una como otra
cualquiera el problema está en que se ha
convertido una etiqueta social que desde
que está la atribuyen te limitan la vida
y esto no es una etiqueta como las que
ponemos de ortega en la camiseta que
atrás y allá a tomar por culo no no no
no está es para toda la vida y claro
en la solución para mí no está en
eliminar este concepto sino en
expandirlo y si digo expandirlo porque
si lo atribuimos a todos se normaliza y
desaparece y diréis me acaba de
llamar discapacitado este chaval si sois
todos discapacitados lo que pasa que no
lo somos como pensamos mi discapacidad
no estaba mis piernas y es más esto mi
madre lo definía de una forma muy bruta
pero muy real decía tan fijo tu vera'
discapacidad no están las piernas no
están la cabeza eres subnormal
y qué razón tenía mi madre
era muy bruta pero lo que quería decir
mi madre era que mis piernas mi
discapacidad no eran las que me van a
limitar mi desarrollo como persona sino
que era mi cabeza mis miedos mis
limitaciones mentales no era eso no
según lo que yo profundizará en mi
cabeza y me enfrentar a estos miedos
determinaría el desarrollo de como yo
que yo tuviera como persona
y clara y te das cuenta como decía que
todos somos discapacitados a quien no
tiene un miedo o un complejo que la
limitado yo tenía miles y ahora mis
piernas era mi cabeza que un cabezón que
te cagas osa no me traen las gorras ni
para un lado ni para otra da igual y
bueno se me cayó el pelo ya no sabes lo
que es levantarse con la mañana con 19
años y ver la almohada llena de pelos
como chico acá vale parecía chewaka
parecía que hablaba en su idioma y todo
era muy duro si analizamos estos dos
estos dos ejemplos que dado que
podríamos las miles ayuda a un grupo de
otros otros miles realmente son banales
y aparte de ser banales
están basados en ese miedo a no ser
aceptado y es que nos pasamos la vida
buscando la aceptación fuera de nosotros
en vez de dentro de nosotros que es
donde está y claro cuando te das cuenta
esto dice esos días te hace click la
cabeza y él ha movido ha cambiado porque
ya no va de analizar la sociedad para él
porque no te aceptan sino analizar te a
ti mismo para ver porque me late estás
tú y empieza a profundizar en mí ya
darme cuenta de la cantidad de
personajes sociales que yo había
generado para ser aceptado y ser feliz
que los tenía todo es el típico no de
tipo duro que nada de duele y puede con
todo el conformista que todo le vale con
olvidada sonriente que toda la fe risa o
bien ni la fuerte ni la duro ni una
feliz estaba roto por dentro tenía
tantos bloqueos que no me permitían
querer ni a los que deberían de ser mis
seres queridos mis padres y darse cuenta
de esto duele pero claro tengo que tener
en cuenta que crecer duele y lo que
estaba pasando estaba creciendo
y en ese momento digamos que mi vida
cambia porque es el punto de inflexión
porque es cuando yo por primera vez
siento a ese niño pequeño que todos
tenemos en mi caso herido y con bloqueos
y lo abrazó abrazó su dolor a sentirse
rechazado abrazó sus miedos a sentirse
solo incomprendido
también abrazó sus errores ese niño que
había hecho bullying en el colegio para
sentirse aceptado igual que había
tratado mal a sus padres porque no
entendía por qué no aceptaba la
discapacidad como la vida
y como decía todo cambia lloré con una
magdalena eso sí me caigan las lágrimas
por todos lados pero con esa lágrima
dulce y poder moflete
es la primera vez que me dejó sentir
vulnerable y a la vez que me dejó sentir
vulnerable es la primera vez que dejo de
confrontar con la vida para conectar con
ella o sea mi vida había cambiado y
ahora tenía un color y una sencillez
sencillez maravillosa y es que me había
dado una página plenitud increíble ya me
da igual que me mirara el raro lo que
pensaban de mí
taiana feliz y quiero que quede claro en
este punto que estamos una charla de
como supere discapacidad sino de cómo
profundice en ella vale en mí a través
de ella más que nada porque la
discapacidad fue un catalizador un
sopapo de realidad que desde minuto uno
me conecta con el sufrimiento ya su vez
me conecta con la vida y es de lo último
que os quiero hablar de esa conexión y
para ello os voy a hablar de una persona
que para mí es muy importante que se
llama izan y es un niño con autismo
severo normalmente cuando hablamos del
autismo
hablamos pensamos que son gente
desconectada que está en su mundo no se
entera de nada pues no para mí el
autismo es conexión es energía es pureza
es magia lo que ocurre que nos
intentamos comunicar con ellos no en un
idioma de pensamiento un idioma cargado
de esos bloqueos y sonidos que se
hablaba antes no que impide conectar con
la gente 3 claro es imposible conectar
con ellos y es cierto que izan no habla
no le hace falta a él no le hace falta
preguntarme david foley a él ya lo sabe
y os juro que es la persona que más me
ha transmitido y abrazado con una simple
mirada y repito tiene autismo severo y
me atrevo a decir que es la persona que
a día de hoy más cambia al mundo bueno
una de ellas y sabéis por qué porque
izan te toca el corazón a mí me lo tocó
tan fuerte que gracias a él
sufrí este cambio no me di cuenta de que
ya toda mi vida buscando aceptación
fuera de mí cuando realmente estaba
adentro por eso tenéis que aprender de
él no y empezar a vivir la vida de
verdad porque la grandeza no se mide en
a la estatura ni los conocimientos que
no tiene ni por supuesto los likes que
tienes en instagram sino los corazones
que tocas y ethan es muy grande claro
que es diferente pero es como tú por eso
tenemos escarbar en nosotros encontrar
esa diferencia que nos hace especiales y
potenciarla porque ser diferente
o como digo yo ser anormal es la
y vaya la gente